hey luca was dein lieblingsessen pizza
ist doch klar
damit herzlich willkommen wir heute
meine lieben freunde zu einer neuen
episode wales mit luca
[Musik]
du weißt auf ihrem bett aussieht
punkt.de keinen sinn warum machst du
jetzt die ganze stimmung kaputt was für
eine stimmung was laberst du ja ich
dachte wir schreiben jetzt bisschen
momente hin und her dies das nie alter
wtf mir geht's nicht gut ich brauche
einen brot zum reden etf ach so toll
dachte halt wegen bett und alleine man
kunden klar junge ja
o
hey in russland hat einfach ein
zwölfjähriger gleichzeitig gegen die
zehn besten schachspieler des landes
gespielt alter krank ja er jedes spiel
verloren
warum sagst es dann grund bist du schon
herangekommen nee ich bin noch nicht mal
drin
wtf bist du vorm krankenhaus oder was ja
warum alter ist alles so voll mit
carnevals besoffenen vollidioten hart
aber ich darf mein bier nicht mit rein
nehmen
lobenswert
wieder komplett beschissener start
wissen die folge habe es endlich
hingekriegt meine autokorrektur
auszustellen aha hat ja die einstellung
nie gefunden auf meinen neuen handy
stellt sie besser wieder an da würde ich
dir einfach mal zustimmen marius hast du
eventuell zeit mir beim handy suchen zu
helfen ich habe das teil wieder verlegt
wo von schreibst du mir denn gerade
fragezeichen
mama sagt das bitte nicht papa
h
eltern kennt die ich habe rolle
daten für veganer gekochten 1 schickt
man ein foto und das ist der rollbraten
für veganer
[Musik]
die ganze zeit gesehen
dazu wild dicker kannst du dich noch an
die sache erinnern was meinst du hast du
hast die ganze zeit den wassermann
angeschrieben von wegen hör auf zu
heulen
wtf hahahaha ja und dann kamen die
nachbarn vor real das weiß ich auch
nicht mehr wegen mucke zu laut oder was
nebra weil sie kein heißes wasser mehr
hatten weil du den wasserhahn die ganze
zeit auslaufen lassen
ich frage mich bei seiner chance hat
richtig auf
ich frag mich bei solchen whatsapp fans
halt einfach nur fragen sich ob die
geschichte wahr ist
ich muss sie enttäuschen sie liegen
daneben sie ist freilich künftige chef
ich kann den bergs laden nicht mehr
sehen ich bin ich dein chef hobby
antwort die personen sechs stunden
später und um 12 uhr als die software
dann auch wach war schreibt der boarder
sich zwei turbos eingespeichert haben
wir gerade meine alles klar bin jetzt
übrigens zu hause angekommen war echt
hammer fete welcher mensch schreibt
peter althammer fete und nochmal danke
dass du dich so lieb um mich gekümmert
hast war echt ziemlich betrunken aber du
hast du ja nachher auch noch ordentlich
ein rhein gekippt als ich dann abgehauen
bin hoffe also dass es sie auch gut geht
gute nacht und eine halbe stunde später
antwortet die person 4
ja
ich glaubte er hat sich wirklich noch
ordentlich gut an rhein gekippt weißt du
wie pilze heißen die springen können die
wtf champignons
die ganze folge ist wieder so blech
alter wie viele flaschen
wenn wir heute noch mal geholt bei aldi
5 ich dachte nur vier harvey gaal ja du
sagst ja auch noch mit dem auto
ich sag's wie es ist
ich weiß nicht
wer euch
indien
reingepackt hat weißt du woran alle
menschen bisher gestorben sind woran am
tod
[Musik]
was war das doch machen
ich wieder nach hause schicken warum
also hier gerade nicht einem freund
sondern alina schreibst schweizer
baloise or ii x3
wenn wir in monga spielen würden und ich
wäre lila welche farbe würdest du dann
nehmen was das für eine dumme frage ja
sag mal schwarz dachte du sagst jetzt
pink oder so weil es wieder am
ähnlichsten sieht sie aber warum denn
schwarz und dann antwortet er mit diesem
foto und man bislang eher dran kommt man
noch bissl mehr
ich hab zum herzen nimmt
wer denkt dass man
ob dies reichen funktionierende
beziehung ist
nach bettler
wie nennt man ein trauriges konto ortega
ich will gar nicht weiter lesen du wirst
es mir vermutlich gleich sagen iv
einigung
das
bist du
eine flasche wie nennt man einen keks an
der zimmer habt ihr mir hier nur wie
nennt man ihn nennt man einen keks an
der börse in kitas ist ein börsen kicks
dkd spekulatius
das
wundert mich irgendwie gar nicht mehr
haben so betrunken war ich gar nicht
alter du hast mit deiner eigenen
freundinnen geflirtet ja und du hast sie
gefragt ob sie single ist ja und ist so
lustig sie hat ja gesagt
menschenrechte sind ziemlich abstoßend
jährlich sterben 15 menschen an den
folgen einer nicht richtig eingestellten
zahnbürste bcf stimmt das nein warum
schickst du mir das dann weil du mir auf
meinem vorherigen nachrichten die
letzten tage nie geantwortet hast du
schuld es mir noch 50 euro erzählen wir
mehr über die zahnbürsten besser kommen
nun allerdings auch schon zum letzten
mal fällt fürs heutige video und fragt
ob jemand was ist 473 mal 41 und die
andere person antwortete direkt 19 1393
und 410 1854 geteilt 134 das sind 3000
66 07
und was ist die wurzel aus 13 1954 118
13 wie kannst du so schnell binnen
sekunden richtig ausrechnen alter bist
du ein stein höchstpersönlich oder was
britta mein handy besitzt einen
taschenrechner
[Musik]